hi everyone i'm scarlett johansson and
i'm here with my black widow co-stars
florence pew and david harbour back
together again
we're gathered here today to look at
your tweets and guess which one of us
the tweet is about let's do this can we
talk about the immaculate music taste
blank has i know that's not me it's
probably like florence but immacula is a
bit too squeaky clean yeah
i knew it it's so cool right okay wait i
just found out blank is a twin was this
common knowledge baller it's about
scarlet got scarlett she's the twin
just came here to state my excitement
about blank doing a russian accent in
the black willow trailer i'm in rachel
i'm just gonna say rachel too
come on
you're gonna give this one to rachel
vice none of you are excited about my
russian accent
[Music]
i'm obsessed with blank's tea tutorial
that's got to be florence yeah yeah
that's me do you make like cups of tea
and stuff yeah
you put the milk in first like the
british no that is crazy
is that the serious question can you
believe it the earth is a billion years
old and you managed to live the same
time as yeah that's scarlet because i
feel that too me too what's that
supposed to mean i don't understand this
tweet
basically someone's really happy that
they're living in the same period of
time as you oh right as opposed to like
medieval times
why does blank new york loft look like
my entire pinterest that's david yeah
that's david and you know that's like a
13 year old girl who's saying that i
showed that to my designer i was like
this is alison from junior high's
pinterest i wanted to look exactly like
that
[Music]